bonjour je m'appelle Gervais Lesage je
suis front d'acteur de pragmasola Pragma
solar accompagne les particuliers dans
leur démarche vers une installation
photovoltaïque
[Musique]
propose au niveau d'un quartier à des
particuliers de se regrouper entre eux
donc dans le but de faire une accusation
groupée d'une installation enfin
d'installation solaire individuelle donc
c'est chacun dispose de son installation
solaire mais on le fait dans une
démarche commune
[Musique]
la démarche de ce regrouper entre
particuliers entre voisins permet au
niveau d'un quartier par exemple d'avoir
une homogénétaire chez cultural au
niveau des toits ça permet de se
rassurer ça permet d'être en confiance
avec un installateur et du côté de
l'installateur local lui salu permet
effectivement d'avoir un groupe de
clients et d'avoir une démarche assez
clair pragmatique et économique aussi
puisqu'on arrive à avoir des coûts
d'installation qui sont de 10 à 15%
moins cher que si le particulier faisait
une installation on va dire solo tout
seul dans son coin
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a travaillé déjà sur
plusieurs quartiers donc il y a deux qui
sont réalisés donc avec différentes
installations sur chacun de ces
quartiers donc c'était une démarche de
dire assez conviviale même entre voisins
[Musique]
ce serait également de travailler donc
sur des d'autres types de groupements il
y a une synergie par exemple à avoir
avec
les pompes à chaleur panneaux solaires
plus pompe à chaleur c'est quelque chose
qui fonctionne très bien ensemble et qui
améliore le processus économique les
véhicules électriques et le solaire
aussi améliore le système économique
donc voilà on peut multiplier entre la
production et l'usage de l'électricité
et
justement aussi travailler au niveau des
entreprises et des collectivités dans
des systèmes qui seraient d'échanger de
l'électricité entre les particuliers les
entreprises et les
collectivités et ça c'est un autre
système qu'on appelle l'autoconsommation
collective donc ça on est au tout début
de l'aventure
[Musique]
de ce qui cube nous a accompagné dans
toute la démarche de création
d'entreprise et dans la réflexion autour
du marché de l'approche client donc avec
un accompagnement qui a été fait par des
professionnels des entrepreneurs donc
c'est tout à fait intéressant de ce
confronter avec ses pairs